no
no i've not heard of that you've not
heard of that uh
miss j paul one of the members of the
house
has introduced a bill and basically i
think the essence of that legislation
is this instead of trying to
organize all these different efforts and
create all these facilities etc etc
we should basically pay
people what they would be earning on
their job
if they were as they were working up to
about 90
000 and let them pay their rent
and let them pay their bills uh in the
way that
they would normally do it now i don't
know exactly how this would work with
the ppp and the small businesses
but what do you think about that idea
well i
i can give it some thought and you know
provide an answer for the record for the
for the hearing i mean i it it off hand
uh you know it has the the benefit of uh
you know going direct to individuals
without through intermediaries i'm not
sure how you'd execute it though
to to ensure that you have accurate
information
uh but uh i'll be happy to think more
about it
and uh give you any thoughts that i have
well
uh let me present a little year for a
moment yes sir on that question
well let me refer you to there are
several
european countries have used this
approach
and so i don't know that it may not be
yet to take a look
at the experience that they've had there
uh
and maybe let us know what you think
about it
okay uh yeah we'll we'll do okay i will
do that
well of course i think by now we all
know a lot about what happened with ppp
we know that the banks executed the
program for us uh
essentially and um that
they took many of them or some of them
took care of their concierge clients
first
they set up a portal uh i talked with a
couple of ceos
and they admitted what they had done are
you aware of that
uh yes yes that yeah that yeah but
we won't be able to get that uh type of
detail until we get the data
you know from sbs you know that the
banks
some of them i'm not saying all of them
but some of the banks set up special
porters
for their concierge clients and those
turned out to be the ones
who got the largest uh amounts of loans
and tell me how did it happen
that these hotels and these restaurants
were able to identify um
each of their installations under 500
people
that they could get paid uh get along
for all of them how did that happen um
my understanding of that is that that
was a
change that was made in the legislation
at the last minute to
to allow them to be able to do that that
that i was part of the original
legislation it's my understanding
you know i if i'm wrong i'll provide a
correction the answer
and to the record for the record but uh
that that allowed those that industry
to apply if they had 500 people less
employees
per location did the sba
sign off on that pardon me did sba sign
off on that
um i don't know their involvement in the
legislation
i'm sure the administration did if if
the president
hasn't signed the bill do you think that
basically
undermined uh what the ppp was supposed
to be about
well i you know i wouldn't second guess
the congress and what it did and what
you know and the legislation that it
passed so
i mean i was assuming that was part of
congressional intent if it's in the
legislation
of course for small businesses well
you know congress the legislation
defined what what business businesses
were eligible or not
i mean that that that decision was in
the legislation from my understanding
do you think that the application for
small businesses was too cumbersome
uh we're looking at that issue now we'll
we'll talk to some
small businesses there's been some
concerns about that
as well as the application for loan
forgiveness
uh which we're you know we'll we'll be
looking at that
issue as well but you know in many
respects
they relied on self-certification so
that
it shouldn't have been that big of a
problem but it could have been
but i we just haven't been able to do
the detailed work
yet necessary to do this because we we
want to go out and talk to small
businesses who receive loans
but we don't have that information yet
and
thank you generally the time is expired
the chair now recognizes mr luchtermeier
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
de guerrero and your colleagues for
being with us today i appreciate your
years of service and congratulations on
your anniversary
of service to our country and i
just want to follow up a little bit on
some of the comments that were made with
regards to the ppp program
i served the financial services
committee and part of this actually
comes through so my subcommittee that we
worked a lot with the administration on
these programs and i know that uh for
instance the sba got more money out the
door in 14 days than they normally do in
14 years i mean that's pretty
significant that they were able to do
that
um the error rate that i saw was roughly
280 million dollars out of 350 billion
that was authorized um and that's about
eight
ten thousandths of a percent do you and
your uh
in your years of experience analysis
find any other program that can have an
air factor of less than
eight ten thousandths of a percent
that's a government program yeah
well i i haven't looked at the error
factors if
if if if it's accurate okay if it's
accurate
it is a very good uh record
yeah that's the number that came out of
the from the media and i think that's
the treasury actually knowledge that
that's roughly
what they're having to claw back from
businesses that
should not have got to ppp but that's
that's a pretty good
record of getting out in 14 days that
much money and then only
an air factor of eight ten thousands
similarly uh with the
uh issue with regards to the stimulus
checks going to people who
uh shouldn't get them you made a comment
a while ago about the social security's
death master file
and it's something that you recommended
apparently for a number of years
that we congress have never done in fact
the trump administration
has proposed in every single budget to
give that treasury access to this
and we congress have not done that is
that roughly correct
that's correct and i know treasury i've
talked secretary mnuchin about this and
they headed official this problem could
have been eliminated and alleviated if
we
congress had done our job and allowed
this to happen in previous years
that's a reasonable hypothesis okay
thank you very much for that
um also
your your your uh charge here is to
uh figure the pandemic's effect on
public health
and i want to follow up on that just a
little bit since um we had a report
in one of the local political magazines
chair that uh
roughly 65 000 people die
as a result per month as a result of the
lack of focus
on their health care needs due to
suicides
opioid abuse lack of cancer treatments
heart
conditions that aren't addressed you
know new york city even said they did 80
only
that didn't do 80 of the brain surgery
did your report look at this part of the
healthcare picture because that's about
50 more people dying
because of lack of treatment versus
attention on the covet
yeah we're going to take a look at that
we've been also focused on our report
let me ask
nikki to come up talk about our
healthcare expert to talk about that
we've been trying to focus
on the numbers of the deaths that
are in in over and above what would
normally be expected over a period of
time
and then as one of the factors that
we're looking at
but this issue about the other factors
is very important
issue and so we're going to be looking
more about it nikki
very quickly i've got one more question
certainly just it's
exact type of indicator that we want to
be developing a representative in terms
of the impact on public health
those type of elective procedures i
think people often when they hear
elective think it's
non-essential these are important um
procedures for people in terms of
preventative care
and so we'll be examining how quickly
hospitals get back to providing those
yeah they said in here 650 000 cancer
treatments about half of mr treatment
about 150
thousands in cases typically discovered
each month are not being diagnosed
that's just on the cancer side
uh one more question before i run out of
time here is with regards to
right now there seems to be an increase
in the number of cases that are detected
obviously we're testing more so you
would anticipate more tests
uh a positive test the result of that
have you looked at
the percentage of hospitalizations as a
result of that
and a number of deaths as a result of
that because you would think if the
virus was at its same
potency you would have you would still
have the same number of
hospitalizations you would still have
the same number of deaths but
anecdotally
that's not happening can can you verify
that or you look at that
we are tracking that information both um
it's an important point in terms of
watching the number of cases but
hospitalizations as well as deaths
and the percent positive those are all
indications
in terms of the spread one of the things
we pointed out in our report is that we
do need
better data at the federal government in
terms of hospitalizations for example
uh the number of icu beds that are
filled and that's something we'll be
continuing to try
well it would seem to me you know we had
a last about three weeks ago the
university of pittsburgh medical center
which according to
my somebody told me yesterday is
actually where they did the research and
helped develop the polio vaccine
these are the experts of the experts
they said that
the virus is losing its its potency it's
mutating to a lesser strain which
if they were having more positives but
yet less hospitalizations and less
deaths would seem to indicate that there
this could be the case
so i think this is very important point
that needs to be made
uh with regards to uh the media is only
telling you that the cases are
increasing but it doesn't tell you that
the deaths continue to go down and
hospitalizations continue to go down
as well as most hospitals still have
capacity take care of that all those
factors are important all those data
points are important i would note
hospitalizations and deaths tend to lag
and so it will be important to
track this in the next couple weeks to
see how how that data changes
okay thank you mr chairman i'll go thank
you very much
the chair now recognizes mrs velasquez
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
comptroller
dodaro from the beginning
i have been calling for the
administration to provide congress
and the gao with detailed data regarding
the paycheck protection program
it is our job to be good stewards of
taxpayers dollars and ensure our
programs are working
as we intended in my call with
sba administrator carranza on wednesday
she indicated that both congress and geo
will be receiving loan data today this
is a good step
but we must work to guarantee gao can
interview and collect additional data to
conduct
its oversight responsibility and this
brings me
to my first question mr dodaro
sba indicated to me that they contacted
gao on june 23rd about
transferring full access to all ppp
loan data have you responded to sba and
does gao
have the necessary systems to securely
receive that data uh yes we have
responded to them
uh we're in discussions with them about
the details on how it would be done
and we definitely have the ability to
secure the data we deal with
tax data healthcare data classified
information of all
stripes thank you and in the same vein
has sba indicated a time and date
when they will provide you with access
to
officials so that you can conduct
interviews
i i think there's been one date offered
so far
but i'm not sure about that so uh
you know mr chairman to compare
the loans made by sba on 2019
to what they have done today is
ridiculous
you know they have a cap as to the seven
day
loan program that is the flagship loan
lending program of sba beyond that
they cannot lend any money plus
the cuts that the agency has suffered
under this administration so budgets
has consequences the e-trans system
they shut it down
is a result of the money that has been
cut
so the first the first sba
ig flash report noted that fba
implementation of the ppp
did not align with the cares
objective of prioritizing underserved
and rural markets has gao has been able
to draw
any conclusions as to what
implementation failures led to so many
rural and minority-owned businesses from
being shot out of the ppp program
during the initial rollout
we will be looking at that issue uh but
until we get the information we're not
in a position to
to determine that now they're also uh
from my understanding did not collect
demographic information
and they're trying to collect it as part
of the loan forgiveness application
but it's voluntary so i don't know how
many people are gonna
are gonna submit the information but
we're gonna try to look at that and
that's one of our key
objectives okay so you note sba
experienced i.t challenges such as
crashes to the e-tran
porthole forcing sba to shut down the
site
is gao considering future reports on i.t
issues that that may have resulted
in some businesses not being able to
access loans
while other businesses may have received
more than one loan
yeah we'll we'll take a look at that
issue sir do you think that is
important for uh the small business
committee to have
access to the raw data
so that if we need to make changes
or if the administration come back to us
and say
we need to approve more money and to
provide more relief
how could we assess if the program is
working
as it was intended by congress if we
don't have access to that information
how many times i have requested the
administrator
to come before the committee and
secretary mnuchin
so it is not right and we uh
expect for them to come forward she
committed to me on wednesday
that she will be coming to the committee
when she asked me what what steps
or what intentions you have and the
committee
going forward regarding the program my
answer is
i don't have any data i have no
information to be
able to make any responsible decision
at this point so thank you sir i yield
back
i thank you the chair now recognizes mr
green for five minutes
the spike in new coronavirus cases as
with
all the other public health decisions we
face this year we have to make sure we
take a holistic look at the data
to ensure we have the truth and not some
preferred narrative
it is alarming is the alarming spike in
cases in parts of this country due to
greatly increased spread
or could there be another factor let's
be honest
the united states is testing people for
the coronavirus at unprecedented rates
and more people are willing to go see
their doctor as the country reopens
so of course we will see an increase in
cases some public health experts have
estimated that we have 10 times the
number of cases of coronavirus
than being accounted for in testing
others like dr francis collins the
director of the national institute
of health have observed in the past and
i
quote the number of people who haven't
yet turned up in the health care system
but who already
are infected is probably 100 times the
number of cases you know about
end quote even cnn yes i'm referencing
cnn
reported just this week that a new study
suggests 80 percent of cases were never
reported in the month of march because
we weren't testing as broadly as we are
now
we've known since the beginning that
there were likely far more cases
overall than just the confirmed cases
and as we have ramped up testing
we see that to be the case dr donald
yailey of the university of pennsylvania
reinforced this point
he urged us and i quote to change our
mindset and focus not exclusively on the
number of cases but on the severe
severity of the illness end quote yali
continued and pointed out
quote fewer people are being admitted
and when they are they tend to be much
less sick than at the beginning or the
peak phases of the pandemic
end quote we have to look at the
hospitalization rates in context this
cdc reports
and i quote for 65 years for people 65
years and older
current cumulative covid19
hospitalization rates are within ranges
of cumulative influenza hospitalization
rates
observed at comparable time points
during recent
influenza seasons end quote now that's
good news
and while we're clearly not out of the
woods yet we need to look at the data
in context asserting that the president
has failed to contain the virus because
the cases are going up
is either blindly uninformed or
blatantly
malicious first the goal was to flatten
the curve
not stop every person from getting the
virus that's physically impossible
trust me i'm a physician
any honest broker will realize that
cases are going through the roof because
we're testing through the roof
so what is it we have to have more tests
or now that we are oh my dear the
president's failed us because we're
testing more and they're more positives
i think most people will see the
ridiculous hypocrisy in that
the media continues their narrative
marching in lockstep with my democrat
colleagues
and they ignore the context and the
facts as i came in today
i saw a gentleman running on the
sidewalk there was no one within a
hundred yards of the guy
yet he was wearing a mask while running
this
speaks to the irrational fears this
dishonest representation of the data by
the media has caused
the media also ignores the fact that
reopening society will save lives in
other ways
cancer screenings deemed non-essential
but in reality are very essential
social isolation which has devastating
health care consequences
can come to an end if we open up
and americans can get back to work feed
their families pay their rents and save
for their kids college
other data is also suspicious colorado's
governor just revised the state's death
due to covet deaths due to covid down by
12 percent
because he found that the state's health
department was counting
even automobile accidents from trauma
deaths
as covid if the patient had the virus
that's absurd 12 and my question to you
sir is have you looked into how states
are actually counting their covid deaths
and if so are there other states that
are going to be revising their numbers
down 12 percent
yeah one of the uh findings in our
report
is that the testing data that cdc has
been reporting
is inconsistent and not complete not all
the test data has been reported
uh states are counting different things
differently
uh and it's been a problem so you really
don't have good
reliable data now we were getting ready
to make a recommendation here but on
june
4th cdc finally through secretary of hhs
used the authority congress gave him in
the cares act
to set out testing requirements to all
labs in the country so hopefully the
testing date will get better hopefully
it's not
12 all across the country being revised
down or well maybe hopefully it is and
then we'll get a real accurate
contextual picture
should treasury and irs be doing now to
ensure payments
reach up to 12 million american
non-filers without any further delay
yeah they need to explore different data
sources to try to identify these
individuals that's one of the things
we're going to look at make some
recommendations to them
when will that happen it's just a matter
of some urgency my office and i'm sure
my colleagues offices are just
besieged with people who desperately
need this money yeah we're working on it
i hope to have those recommendations
by our next bi-monthly report okay i'm
working through the weekend
during this pandemic i hope your people
are working through the weekend too we
wouldn't have been able to produce that
report that you have there in 90 days
since the law if we weren't working 24
7.
i appreciate that um ga also reported
that treasury and irs sent nearly 1.4
billion dollars in payments to
1.1 million decedents that is americans
who had already died
and i'd also heard from some honest
constituents who called up and said
we got this check for my wife or my
husband who's no longer with us
irs apparently was aware this was
happening back in march but didn't
begin to correct it until months later
what's up with that that's just shocking
how'd that
happen well uh irs's original
determination was that the law required
them to send a
check to everybody who filed a return in
2018 or 19.
and so they they figured it would
include those people so they they did it
on
with foresight that that's what they
were supposed to do
then wow okay just let me pause you
there because that seems to contradict
common sense in other words
because we said that it should go to
everyone who filed taxes they thought
should go
to people who had died right who had
filed taxes all right well
what is the law because some people were
saying should we cash this check why
would the government be
sending it right yeah no no i agree what
is the interpret what is the correct
correct interpretation we believe is
treasury's
interpretation after that was that the
the intent was to help people
who are affected by the situation which
wouldn't include people who were
deceased
so they stopped it at that point in time
after irs had made the first three
payments so we believe the correct
interpretation now
is they should not have been sent and
our recommendation is to try to get as
much of the money back
as possible okay and they've changed
that policy of sending checks to people
who have died
that's correct okay they stopped that
after the first three rounds
um all right thank you very much and i
yield back mr chairman you very much mr
asking the chair now recognizes mr kim
for fire management
thank you mr chairman i just want to
begin by just addressing something that
came up
earlier in this hearing um it was talked
about cdc guidance when it comes to
wearing a mask
and social distancing i just went onto
the cdc website and just want to confirm
that it says cover your mouth and nose
with a cloth face cover when around
others
and continue to keep about six feet
between yourself and others
it is not saying that it is one or the
other it is recommending
both social distancing and using a mask
moving forward i have to say i'm very
concerned about the trump
administration's failures when it comes
to providing
personal protective equipment and
medical supplies
that our communities need to keep safe
according to the gao's report
there was a hhs exercise in august 2019
that determined quote
that domestic manufacturing capacity
would be unable to meet the demands for
personal protective equipment
and other supplies in the event of a
global influenza pandemic
this was months before the coronavirus
pandemic but the trump administration
failed to act on these findings as a
result according to the gao quote the
nationwide need for critical supplies to
respond to cobit 19
quickly exceeded the quantity contained
in the strategic national stockpile
uh mr comptroller geno i wanted to ask
you do you agree that the strategic
national stockpile had been short of the
critical supplies
that were needed during this pandemic uh
yes
i mean that the the uh and that's been
acknowledged
and they're trying to fix it now and
they're to try to revamp
the stockpile going forward the the uh
exercise that you talk about the crimp
is called crimson contagion
and it was pretty much an exercise that
mirrored what exactly has happened uh
with this particular
covet 19 situation and identified things
now what they told us was they didn't
have
enough time to react to the findings in
there that they did brief
some members of the congress but they're
trying to revamp the national stockpile
now
but the mass that were in there that
were left over from h1n1
weren't effective anymore and so they
had to be
be replaced or they were provided with a
caveat about their potential so what
steps
what steps could have been taken and it
should have been taken to prepare
for this to quickly replenish that
stockpile in your opinion yeah well
i mean uh the the issues we raised this
before in prior administrations as well
that there weren't enough ventilators in
urban hospitals
around the country so we we've raised
these issues over time
our country uh has difficulty
and the hardest part of my job is
getting people to act before there's a
crisis
has great difficulty in preparing ahead
uh for things
and so it's not unique to any
administration
this has been a problem that i've seen
throughout my career in government so
earlier this year they had the
information
and everybody preceding had it in order
to act on it but they just
they didn't either the money wasn't
appropriated they didn't allocate it
properly we're looking more at the
details about it
uh but clearly uh you know steps could
have been taken previously
and recently it was characterized
earlier in this hearing
that some of the problems that we're
facing with the government response were
a few glitches
so would you then categorize the
problems in terms of the supply of ppe
as a few glitches
i i wouldn't categorize it that way now
beyond just the supply side of the issue
it's also about the coordination
side and this was something that that
was raised here i think you wrote
there have been reports that the federal
acquisition and distribution efforts
to the supplement the strategic national
stockpile
supplies lacked coordination and
resulted in challenges
obtaining supplies here how did that
lack of coordination hurt the efforts to
obtain the critical supplies
well i think early on i'll ask miss
clares to elaborate early on
hhs was taking the lead uh here and
there was um
uh later was shifted to fema then the
uh president's uh you know the task
force the white house task force came in
set up the unified command and brought
in people to focus on a supply chain
would you categorize
that as a few glitches as part would you
categorize the problems when it comes to
the coordination as a few glitches that
cause the problems with
getting the ppe to the states and the
hospitals uh
no when it comes to uh one last part
here that i just wanted to address in
your report you said you requested
information on the strategic national
stock law inventory prior to the
pandemic
the types and amount of supplies that
states requested
as well as what hhs and fema distributed
from the strategic national stockpile to
the state's
request you said you did not have that
information as of june 12th
that seems like very basic information
to me about what is necessary to assess
whether the stockpile is doing what it's
meant to do have you received that
information
yet we we have
we have not when did you make that
request uh we've made
i don't have a specific date but it's a
request that we made
fairly early on but we'll continue to
work with hsn have you been given a
reason why you have not been receiving
this
this information uh we have not do you
know how much is in our stockpile right
now
i do not a question is just who pays for
our stockpile
there's a the federal government
provides um
appropriations and as the comptroller
general uh
mentioned uh that's the appropriations
has varied each year over
a number of years in terms of what's
been provided to to
maintain adequate supplies in the
stockpile yeah that's that's absolutely
correct it comes from
our government comes from the american
people it's american people stockpile
and they deserve to know what has been
done to keep them safe
the american people are still under
threat from this virus we face rising
cases across this country
we face a threat of a second wave later
this year and the american people
deserve to know if we're ready
and your testimony and the report today
makes me concerned that we're not ready
mr chairman back to you all right thank
you
thank you gentlemen we uh have uh
had questions from all of our members
i would like now to yield to the ranking
member for any closing
statement he would like to make thank
you again mr chairman
for holding this hearing in this
committee room and and again
uh thank you mr dora for your report
your testimony i appreciate the fact
that you've been working with the trump
administration to get the information
you need to compile this report as well
as to continue
providing us proper oversight and i'm
glad that in your testimony you
made clear that you're getting that
cooperation from the trump
administration clearly
there are other issues you're going to
continue to work through with the small
business administration
as you testified today they have been
overwhelmed
last year they issued about 36
000 loans under the 7a program and
in eight short weeks they issued over
four and a half
million loans through that same program
over 125 percent increase in workload
and in a time where we knew we had to
move expeditiously time was of the
essence to save millions
of small businesses to save millions of
jobs so that families
have the ability to pay their mortgage
to get back to work to
have their careers before them as we
work through this pandemic it's
been unprecedented in terms of the
response
the quickness that we've seen in getting
testing brought to the market
a test that would have taken two years
for the fda to approve
have been approved instead in weeks
following safety guidelines but removing
red tape i applaud the trump
administration for implementing
operation warp speed to push
more results for families to get more
testing to get more
cures therapies we're seeing
revolutionary changes drugs
like remdezavir that are proving
effective for many people
of covet 19 that would not have happened
without the trump administration
moving red tape out of the way so that
we could save lives
uh continuing to search for a vaccine at
rapid speed that we're seeing in the
private sector because red tape has been
cut
we need to continue to push for those
kind
of reforms and that kind of expeditious
response
now clearly when you move expeditiously
uh there can be mistakes made
it's good for us to look at finding out
what those mistakes are
and correct them i'm glad you testified
that you are seeing
agencies like the irs correct things
along the way that they found
but we also have seen that
based on your findings that you
presented so far the ppp program has
more than a 99 success rate
that is revolutionary for a program that
has given out loans to over four and a
half million small businesses
over 500 billion taxpayer dollars that
have been used
properly as we all voted for republicans
and democrats joined together
to say let's help these small businesses
quickly
to have over a 99 effective rate let's
go find
the folks who abused it let's go get
that money back and i'm glad the
administration's working
to do that but for somebody to suggest
that a program that is over a 99
success rate is a failure or shouldn't
have happened is ludicrous
again millions of families would be out
of work
small businesses that would be closed
even with the unemployment numbers we're
seeing each week
those numbers are dropping because
businesses are starting to open again
and again we look
back to the science as dr green talked
about why
did we do this we didn't do this to hope
that
nobody gets coronavirus sure we hope
that nobody gets coronavirus but
in a real world we know it's still out
there and so the question is do we just
shut everything down
and wreck our economy wreck the
livelihoods and again as dr green
pointed out
there are thousands of people dying
because they're staying at home they're
not going to their doctor they're not
getting their checkups and their cancer
treatments and their
colonoscopies and their mammograms and
their immunizations
children will die because they're not
getting immunized so there's a cost
to keeping people at home as well we
need to look at all of that
we've talked in this committee about the
nursing home
crisis that happened yes every state
experienced nursing home deaths but not
all states experienced it
at the same level let's just look at the
data we've gotten so far and again we're
trying to get more data
because some of these states are hiding
the data but what we know
if you look at the five states that
violated the cms guidelines went against
the science
tens of thousands of people died that
shouldn't have died we want to know
about that
i'm glad that you're looking into it and
as mr jordan said we hope that you do
that
quickly as well because we need to stop
it from happening
where it is still going on in states
like michigan where we know this is
killing people to force
nursing homes to take back covet
positive patients if they can't isolate
them
it killed tens of thousands of people
and probably a lot more
i know the chair brought up the state of
texas the state of texas
had 700 percent fewer
nursing home deaths per capita than the
state of new york
of course they had deaths every state
had nursing home deaths
but not all states experienced the same
thing the state of florida
had over 500 percent fewer nursing home
deaths
per capita than the state of new york we
ought to be looking at where it's
working well
where it's working poorly stop it from
working poorly and say
why don't you follow the guidelines that
the folks that are doing it right are
i'd love to have zero nursing home
deaths but 700 percent fewer in one
state
than another you should be looking going
why are they doing it right and why are
they not
and finally mr chairman and to all of
our members i know we're looking
at the icu beds again the economy was
closed down
to make sure our hospitals don't get
overwhelmed and as we speak
today there's not a single state in the
nation whose hospital system
is overwhelmed we've seen spikes clearly
we're following the spikes
and the governors are managing that but
not a single state in this nation has
their hospital system
overwhelmed that was the barometer for
closing the economy down
it's why we need to reopen safely and
again to address the people that are
dying
because things are closed down that has
to be understood
as well so i appreciate the report you
gave i look forward to the future
reports i hope the governors of those
five states
comply with the letter we sent and i'm
gonna get you a copy of this there were
very specific things
we've asked for that they're recording
they're just not sharing it with the
public
we need to know more about what happened
in those states that didn't follow the
federal guidelines
and the result was that thousands of
people died in nursing homes that
shouldn't have
why are they hiding the data what do
they have to hide we ought to find it
out i appreciate that you're going to
join
with us to finally get the facts and
uncover this scandal
with that i yield back i thank the
gentleman of the year i'm back let me
close by thanking uh mr
durataro miss brown
miss claus for being here today
we appreciate all the work you do to
hold our government accountable
especially during this terrible pandemic
today's hearing is made clear
that there are tangible steps the
federal government can take
now to increase transparency
to demand accountability from those
receiving federal funds and to ensure
that tax dollars are used to help the
american people
and are not diverted due to waste
fraud and abuse
i want to thank the iraqi member for
calling attention to
what happened last month and the month
before
in new york i think we all would like to
know what happened last week
uh in south carolina my home state
in georgia in florida
in texas in arkansas in oklahoma
all those states are spiking
within the last week and i'm
interested in last week
and what we can expect next week
as opposed to spend all of our time
trying to figure out where the virus
came from
i would hope that we spent a little time
trying to figure out
where the virus is going
next so as to be prepared for
we've talked a little bit today i
thank the gentleman from illinois for
raising the issue of vaccines
i'm old enough to remember the last time
the country
wrestled with vaccines
i was around i was a school kid
when we had the polio vaccines
there was an s on that jonah salk
came up with a great vaccine
required a shot albert sabin
came up with a great vaccine a little
drop of serum
on a lump of sugar
and according to all the science it was
most
more effective than so
i happen to remember which communities
got stuck in which communities
got saved i grew up
in the communities that got sucked the
least preferred
and the least perfected effective now i
know
they're going to be about 19 they are
about 19 countries
supposedly in search of a vaccine
and uh that's what i want to see this
committee focus on
where what vaccines come forward the
effectiveness of backstage
and where they're allocated
not just the efficiency of the work but
how effective it's going to be
and how equitable they'll be distributed
i grew up a victim
of that which is not
equitable and i'm not going to reside
over a process that will revisit that
or even continue it so he can follow in
the past
i'm going to be concerned about the
future and thinking about the future let
me just read
for our benefit this is the document
from the
attending physician
and i want to read it
for united states house of
representatives meetings
in a limited enclosed space
such as a committee hearing room
for greater than 15 minutes
face coverance are required
in all caps
that's not me that's the attendant
physician
and we're not gonna have another meeting
in a confined space
for less for more than 15 minutes
if we are not going to abide by this
i will stay in the safety of my home
like i would ask all you to do
i grew up believing
that the first sign of a good education
is good manners i think it's good
manners
to look out for you fella then i'll see
all the staff wearing this
i don't know what this is mr chairman
of that i'll be glad i thank the
chairman for yielding and
as dr green pointed out there are
guidelines out there for how to properly
social distance and we're following
those
and again i understand doctors might
look at things differently and want to
give even extra precautions
but the precautions that have been out
there are clearly being followed and dr
green pointed that out and
none of us would want to put anybody
else in harm's way it's why the house
has been
having votes on the house floor safely
properly
with social distancing with the
necessary supplies to make sure we can
wipe down spaces as we're all
you know not here but on in the house
floor we're working
in a similar area speaking at podiums
and as one person moves out they wipe
down the area and another person
uh follows those guidelines just like we
do here
i would yield back mr truman
mr asking ideal to mr asking okay thank
you go ahead no no after you sir okay
please
um i i really wish mr chairman we could
work this out pursuant to
your suggestion following the exact
instructions
of the capital physician look we don't
have a cure right now we don't have the
treatment
and we definitely don't have a vaccine
we've got one thing
which is the public health guidance from
dr fauci
the centers for disease control and the
vast majority of the doctors in the land
who do not think this is a hoax and do
not think this is invented
and they don't think it's political and
there's one thing we can do
we can put our masks on and we can keep
our distance
um and i don't understand why
my friends in the minority who i know
are sincerely motivated people
would lambast the majority for trying to
keep the continuity of government going
with committee meetings
online with remote or through proxy
voting
and say everybody needs to be here
everybody needs to be here and then show
up
and not wear masks and put terror in
fear in your colleagues and perhaps your
staff ms waters lost her sister
to this disease we have lots of
colleagues who've gotten covid19 we've
lost
more than 125 000 of our countrymen
and women there's no other country in
the world in which wearing a mask
has become a political or ideological
statement
it's a public health measure you know
we've got a rule which says
you can't you have to wear a jacket on
the floor of the house and i know
people tease our friend mr jordan about
never wearing a jacket you know
i don't care about his not wearing a
jacket that's a fashion statement
but when he doesn't wear a mask and
interacts with other people in the
legislative assembly
it's dangerous that is a public health
menace
so could we all agree that we will abide
by
the chairman's suggestion and the
capital physicians
um strict recommendation and let's go
forward and let's try to meet together
as much as possible
as opposed to driving us away from the
capitol
but could i ask my friend in reference
to mr jordan i think you used the term
public menace i i that's not a pride i
hope you weren't referring to him oh
he walked out of here with a mask on he
walked with him he walked within one
foot of our friend mr green i saw it
happen and they whispered to each other
and it happens all the time
you know we might think we're in these
six-foot bubbles but we're not and i see
it happening on the floor
on both sides of the aisle you start to
hang around with people we're social
beings and people
begin to interact did you see what
happened in the pennsylvania legislature
where one of the legislators came down
with it um
told his party but didn't tell the other
party it created
absolute panic and more division why are
we the only country on earth
where this is now a matter of polemical
partisan debate
instead of just public health order why
don't we just follow what the public
health authorities
authorities are telling us to do so
recognizes mr green mr chairman let me
say before i
i cite this uh study that just came out
june the 27th
uh that if you if you you know
put the gavel down and say we want to
wear masks or we're going to require
i'll wear my mask but i i do want to
inform
the the committee the lancet published
just on june 27th a meta-analysis a
meta-analysis is where they look at
all these other studies and they compile
the data
and draw conclusions with hopefully more
confidence because they're looking at
multiple studies
they looked at 172 studies across 16
countries on six
continents they found that a one meter
distance
increased it it decreased your risk
with moderate certainty now when they do
these meta analysis
they say high certainty the data is
convincing enough to say that there's
high certainty that the conclusion is
accurate there's moderate certainty and
then there's low certainty on the mask
issue it was low certainty
that it makes a difference the new
england journal of medicine one of the
most respected journals in the nation
had an article several weeks ago that
said outside the healthcare setting
the masks don't work now it was
referenced earlier about fomites and
but yet documents are being passed
around in here all the time
are we sterilizing each document before
we hand it off to one another i i
haven't seen that
this mask that was sitting outside is
there for anyone they could go to the
bathroom and
and come in and pull a mask out and
touch other masks
in the stack and then the next person
comes along and collects the mask
we're not doing surgical sterilization
here
and i just want us we have to be
consistent and if you say green i want
you to wear a master i'll wear a mask
you're the chairman of my committee but
i want us to to make decisions based on
sound
data and information thank you sir will
you hear it for question
yes sir i will are you arguing that we
should not meet in person
no no sir not at all i think some of
this social government is american to me
no i don't think because of all because
there's no certainty
the mass may not work but we know how
the disease
is transmitted so then that mask has
such a low
probability of working maybe we ought
not be meeting in person
if you're asking my clinical opinion sir
yes
my opinion is is that patients who are
in high risk
categories
sure anyone who's 65 years or older uh
that has comorbidities should wear a
mask
if you don't i'm telling people in
tennessee
it's not required but mr chairman can i
ask about that
as i understand it the mask is not to
protect
me it does it gives me a little
production but it's protect other people
in the event
that i'm infected and a majority of the
infections i understand
are of people who are asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic so you don't know
whether you've got it
we have members of congress who didn't
realize they had it
and they were fraternizing with
everybody else and any of us would do
that if that were the rule
so why is this so complicated there's
one thing we can do to try to protect
other people more together which is put
on a mask
it doesn't cost us anything why would we
not do that why is it some kind of macho
thing like if i don't wear a mask
i'm tough you know i think you know if
you want to be tough
go spend a day with the nurses and the
doctors in the hospital
and all of them come out and say
everybody wear your mask listen to them
you don't want to spend the day with
them at least listen to them all of the
first responders are saying
save us from this nightmare wear your
mask so
i can cite many other professionals who
are saying just the opposite and i
i i so that's that's the challenge we're
in right we're saying don't wear a mask
when i'm around i'm i'm not wearing a
mask no um
could you send us the medical advice
that people not wear a mask because i
haven't seen that
i can share some medical literature with
you with me against the centers for
disease control
i know what they're putting out harvard
university johns hopkins all the studies
i've seen
okay let me thank you mr chairman for
okay
without the objection all members will
have five
legislative days within which to submit
additional written questions for the
witnesses to the chair
which will be forwarded to the witnesses
for their response
i ask our witnesses to please respond
properly as promptly as you are able to
with that this year end is a term
so that we have the work done
a long list of things
thank you so much
[Music]
me
[Music]
yes
what
[Music]
you